hello everyone i'm alana and i am joined
by patricia hernandez today who is the
new editor-in-chief of kotaku newish
it's not that you know it's been a while
um and i just wanted to talk to you
about the state of games media uh what
it's like taking over a website right
now and uh the letter from the editor
that you released basically when you
took on this new role which congrats by
the way but also just basically for my
starting question
um what is your
goal with kotaku and what do you do when
you you know have the opportunity to
become the editor
in chief of a major video game website
at this point in time
uh
well you know i think that's the daily
question right
right now it's a little bit of just
ambient terror and realizing how much
power
i technically have uh which is like a
weird thing to say but like
it's
potentially yeah it's weird because like
if i describe the stuff in the letter
about like wanting to do things
differently and like wanting to like not
just because i feel like there's just a
lot of like very rote coverage
in games media like you know
every time fortnite announces a
crossover it's a headline but they've
announced like
10 this week they've announced so many
this week
and
i would like to imagine that there's a
world in which
games media doesn't have to do that i
think in a lot of cases when games media
tries writing for like everyone they end
up writing for like no one
um
and in practice like
i don't know kotaku has the tagline
that's like the the gamer's guide right
and
we used to take that very seriously in
the sense that like
i don't know like considering what the
gamer would want to read right like and
usually that meant like we have to cover
all the big games all the big games
because that's what people expect when
they load off the site you know they if
a big company announces a big game it's
going to be on the page
and now i'm just kind of of the mind
where it's like well i don't i don't
know what the purpose of that is like i
know that the people that i've hired are
talented and i don't know that i want to
waste their talents just like rewriting
yeah yeah
and like you know on a day like today i
was talking about this in twitter a
little bit but i deleted the tweet
because i felt like it was being taken
very poorly by some people where like
there's some leaks about the new call of
duty and then there's like something
about the battle new battlefield mode
which like
there's nothing wrong with those games
but given that we only have like a
handful of writers right now and there
are all these like
big
like complicated stories that are
breaking
it seems like a better use of our time
to focus on like the things that we can
report originally versus like
some leaks new new call of duty that you
i mean you you would expect a new call
of duty every year right like in that
sense
but i said this on twitter and some
people were like well you know like i
it's weird that i can't go to kotaku for
that sort of stuff like why like are you
telling me they have to go somewhere
else to learn about the
the news
which is kind of like a hard question
because it's you know i guess in a
perfect world maybe we would be like
experts on like
everything but from
my viewpoint i know that we've always
left
a ton of games on the table you while
like convincing everyone that like where
the gamer's guide and like we cover all
the biggest stories or whatever but like
what is considered important usually the
scope is very small right like you could
have a website that's like entirely just
like patch notes of all the biggest
games because they
upload they change every week or
whatever
and i'm not saying that we won't publish
patch notes because you know sometimes
they're interesting
but i i just want to get to a point
where the choices that we make feel
intentional and not just well this is
what we've always done and we have to
what you're supposed to do yeah i mean
it's an interesting conundrum to have
especially when you do have a limited
amount of writers and you're also
competing with twitter like that was the
thing that became obvious to me even as
i was leaving ign that i feel like has
only gotten worse now is
the amount of people who can cover
something before
you can get it up on kotaku there's
already several tweets out there's an
image out everyone's already got that
news so is it valuable at the end of the
day like it's already all over every
other platform of course not everyone
uses twitter we're just saying that
before we start recording yeah but i
mean it is an interesting thing and i
remember when um halo infinite got
delayed
i had that news at the same time as
probably every journalist but i got a
video up before any of the
major games media websites did because
i'm just one person and i can record to
a camera and hit send but there's so
much that needs to happen when you run a
game site to get that news up at the
same amount of time became very very
clear to me as i was leaving ign is like
we are so [ __ ] slow when it comes to
news that i don't know if it's even
valuable anymore to try to compete with
youtubers and that was a question that i
wanted to ask that you sort of brought
up there is
how much do you consider you know the
way people on twitch are covering games
and the way people on youtube are coming
games as competition or as a way to grow
like how do you look at that side of the
industry i think it's
i mean everyone likes to pose
journalists as in competition with like
influencers and stuff and
i can see why people do that and
especially if you're like a youtuber
who's like kind of like
has like a very like abrasive
personality i think it's kind of in your
favor to
draw up targets right to like draw a
line in the sand and then fans get very
like
you know
the whole thing with parasocial
relationships it's hard for me to look
at
i don't know like twitch influencers or
youtubers as competition and it's not
because out of like lack of respect or
anything like that but
because we report on them right so like
i don't know we we cover them we i think
we consider them more like
a part of the and like big uh
influential people in the industry that
like in some ways are
i know this is gonna get taken out of
context but like
are more well-known than the average
game developer i guess which is true you
know
there are problems with that being true
but like i think it says
a lot that like i don't know dr
disrespect just announced a new studio
and it's like specifically to pair
influencers with
with the games and stuff like
yeah i don't know i i think our
priorities are very
different uh right like uh
you don't have to
break news as a youtuber although you
can
whereas i think the expectation at a
site like otaku or at least so far has
been that like we're very tied with news
right telling you what's going to happen
before it's out there
and stuff like that um
and a lot of times
i feel like it's kind of like a not a
symbiotic relationship but you know like
if we break news
usually what happens is the youtuber
will cover it and they'll give their
opinions and like involved people will
follow
yeah yeah for sure
because they gotta get those ten minute
videos out so they can get the ads in
but to jump off of that i mean how do
you feel about the state of games media
right now just in general where is it at
and how do you feel about it
i feel frustrated about it a lot but
it's it's weird because i look at what's
out there right now and
objectively there's like more types of
writing now than there ever has been for
more types of voices and stuff like
and also just like more better reporting
i feel like everyone's kind of within
the last year seeing how important it is
to actually have like
sources and all this other stuff to like
be able to tell these
complicated sensitive stories that like
are shrouded in a lot of like ndas and
stuff like that but i think my
frustration with it is born out of love
right like feeling like we could be
doing
more interesting stuff feeling a little
bit of jealousy that sometimes you know
like
we have to make decisions as to like
what a good use of our time is and maybe
this has not happened during my tenure
at kotaku but i've definitely seen
situations where it's like do i cover
this small game that no one knows or do
i cover the thing that i know is going
to do traffic and in the best
world you balance a little bit of the
two right but yeah i think it's just
very easy to like
only care about the things that you know
like
i feel like there's not a lot of
starting conversations there's a lot of
trying to follow
trends
yeah is is what i perceive but you know
at the same time
i look at sites like polygon and ign
they're led by like very smart people
like i i don't think that uh the state
of games media is is like
well obviously it's not malicious like
no one wants to create
a thing that feels boring or rhodes
right
i think maybe where
where we
are a little different is that yes
technically we are a news site but i
also just have like little
personal investment in being seen as
like professional and stuff like that
like i think it's more important for me
to feel like you are reading something
true when you go to the website
than it is and feeling like i don't know
we are
capital j journalist even though
obviously we are i don't i i understand
i completely understand what you're
trying to say completely because there
are uh restrictions that come with being
capital j fancy journalists
that i think don't necessarily speak to
the average gamer either you know there
are
restrictions that you can place on
yourself with that kind of thing um like
for example with the kotaku headline
that had [ __ ] in it
i understood the criticism with that and
had my own criticisms but my criticism
was not actually the the word [ __ ]
because i don't understand why when we
know the kind of people who play video
games why it was like this pearl
clutching thing that kotaku said [ __ ]
uh i again get the criticism of it being
a very negative thing but at the same
time it was very confusing to me because
youtube is appraised for being that
negative at the same time oh my god yeah
it's a bad game
but it's it was definitely a thing that
it was like why are we against you know
we play video games they're full of
swear words
gamers probably swear a fair amount on
on the whole it's very odd to be upset
about the word
[ __ ] being used in a hotel a little back
at the level of
response to that i mean
you know not to wash my hands of it but
i wasn't like involved in the decision
making for that headline but
i think even if i had been i would not
have anticipated that quite that um
reaction and i get it you know i get on
a lot of different levels like
we
we do curse i would like to be more a
little bit more selective on it uh i
don't know if the uh some random mobile
game was like worth pulling a thing that
is supposed to be like
but you know on the other hand i know i
would have felt something if like luke
wrote like a very
straightforward headline and then
tweeted it like
this look this game is [ __ ]
then i'd be like well why isn't that in
this in the
reflected like from the second that
before you even click on the story
sure um
but i also know that like
yeah from the from the game developer
side i kind of understand that obviously
you don't that's not like the most uh
what is the word polite not terribly
constructive not terribly supportive
like i really did get the criticism yeah
yeah
and see that's an interesting question
to me too because like
in
in many ways it's not our job to
fix the industry but that doesn't mean
that we can't contribute to it because
like right like what role does uh
reporting take it can
be used in cases or whatever like uh it
can it can help people or
there's this whole concept of like
solutions based journalism like there
are pathways to do it but i also think
the
the conversation gets a little muddied
when it's like
i don't like considering us a part of
the industry which in some ways i guess
we are if we're talking about like
influencers and stuff like that but i i
think i would rather consider myself
like
outside of the industry trying to to
look in which has its limits but
i think that's that's part of where
that came from when it's like well
you're you're not being very
constructive and it's like well i've
i don't know you're too you're 2k you
don't you pay focus testers you fix it i
hmm but i but i get it right like
yeah if you just i all right what god
explained to me not that it needed to be
explained was like
kind of feeling like developers are
constantly reading like very just like
acerbic
[ __ ]
over like nothing right like that's the
the basis of any conversation where like
i don't know you
you nerf a character or something and
suddenly people are like yelling at you
for no reason
so in that sense i kind of get that it's
like oh big account also kind of
sounding like a i don't know like a
redditer or something like somebody
tweets at them
yeah yeah so in that sense i kind of get
it
but the tough decisions to make that's
the things like thinking about how to
approach this kind of stuff is a lot
harder than i think
anyone realizes it is very tough and
also i've had definitely had the thing
of uh writing something when i was ign
and people being mad and i was like i
did not see this one coming
oh my god i did not know they'd be upset
about that they're always so like so
convinced that you like you knew what
you were doing when you were publishing
this like oh my god yes i feel like i
get some of the wildest uh
accusations on twitter where i'm like
okay
clearly we don't agree but i wish you
weren't writing this weird fan fiction
about like my motivations you can just
say that you don't like why you don't
agree with the thing drives me nuts uh
to circle back a little bit
this is a is a pretty broad question but
what actual purpose do you think games
media should serve
man i don't i feel like if would i the
way that i look at it is i wake up every
day kind of hoping to entertain people
or at least drive their curiosity
sometimes that might be you know
informing them of
like truths that they might not be able
to get otherwise because we have access
but like
i don't know it's funny that like
there's this sense that games
journalists are like this very like
unhappy very like pessimistic bunch when
i feel like the reason that we like
games is because we
like to have fun i assume is is
somewhere in there and i
yeah i would rather wake up and like
find like the cool weird thing in the
new pokemon game than like deliver you
news that uh
i don't know some assault has happened
somewhere sure
um and i don't know if that maybe drives
like
i don't know if it if i should be
looking at myself more as like a
journalist first and foremost because
technically that is what we are but
i think
i look at it more as like if we
if we can get paid to write for a living
i want to make that writing feel
worthwhile or interesting or like the
the in the best possible scenario i'm
like sharing
a thing that i am excited about or that
i think there's value in and then you
can like you can also maybe learn that
like you love this thing that you didn't
know that you loved or liked are willing
to try a new thing like
but at the same time yeah i do think
that there's like
uh responsibility with the platform
right so
using
and aside from entertaining also using
our voice wisely
taking punches when needed um jumping
off of that what are the hardest parts
of the job the things that people
you think don't see or don't know about
the things that are just huge silent
challenges i would say that just the
sheer amount of time both to report or
even become like an expert in a in a
game right like
i think it's very easy to criticize if
like
because think about how games live out
in the world right i think the average
person isn't playing like 10 different
games every week
to go along with the releases they're
probably going to play like a handful of
things
usually probably what happens is that
people are very focused on a single game
right and so you think
it's the last stat that i read most
people get very into three games per
year
so so think about that seems like right
like
there are many different implications
there but one of the most pressing ones
i think for a game journalist is the
average person might genuinely know a
game better than you do and it's not
because you're not good at your job it's
because
our jobs are to like kind of know a
little bit of everything and if you have
been playing league of legends for the
last six years like of course you're
going to know that game better than
probably most
uh mainstream journalists i should say
it's an interesting point it's like you
can get criticism for
not knowing something with the amount of
depth of someone who only plays that one
thing all day every day but they
couldn't do your job because they don't
play enough games but how do you
communicate that without being like well
yeah you do know this game better than
me
yeah sometimes i see controversies pop
up where it's like you know you
criticize something in the game and it's
like
well in the 85th hour if you had done
this then you would have gotten this
ending and that's not actually what
happens but you didn't play the game
correctly and and it's just like oh like
oh the i feel like the the
the standards that are being put out
there are just so unrealistic and
especially when like the a good modern
game either
never ends because it's continually
updated or like i don't know think of
the average assassin's creed game and
how long it takes to experience
everything in that game
i it yeah it i think that the time
commitment
which is funny because
you know we're we consider it so
important to report on crunch and yet i
think i do not know of a single person
that like
works
decent hours no there are there are
massive struggles then and things that i
think people don't see and one thing
that i'd love to ask you about because
i've always said that even when i was an
editor at ign i it's not that i didn't
care it's that i didn't obsess over it
in the way that the public thought
uh how much attention are you actually
paying to clicks how much attention are
you actually paying to especially in
your job role uh to here's how many
views the site got in this day because
of course when i was a writer
in games media i was writing about
trending games but i wasn't going i need
a hundred thousand views i just didn't
think about anything that way
well
that's an interesting question because
you know i came up
during the gawker days and it was very
cutthroat like when you would walk into
the office
not that i was in the office but like
this just to give you a sense of the
environment like you would walk in
and there would immediately be like a
leaderboard with like the top stories
and
while that changed iterations there was
always some version of it um
back when it was like
nicked in and stuff like that
and like you know
i think about like
what type of people gamers are right and
like at the end of the day i do think we
are kind of numbers people were like
what do we do in games right we go and
optimize and like try to get like the
best possible gear and stuff like that
all this to say is that i do
pay attention but i also think
it can't be the end-all be-all of
whether or not something is is worth
covering because then yeah you just end
up
covering the same the same [ __ ] right
i'm probably in
like things like chart b which is the
thing that like
tracks the numbers and stuff like
more than i should be but i i also
partially do it so that the writers
don't have to worry about it like i do
not want a world in which
you know someone is not going to pitch
something that they actually care about
just because they don't think it's going
to do
well
like at our best
we do the stuff that we know is going to
do well
to give us a cushion to do the the stuff
that we care about and sometimes they
intersect that they're not always like
at odds with you know like i'm a big
pokemon fan and so and pokemon generally
does
numbers uh but i'm not writing it
because it does numbers it's i'm just
like already in in the fandom and such
so
i'll ask you my last question then um
what do you want kotaku's relationship
with the audience to be
you know that's a good question and one
that i've been thinking about a lot
recently within the context of like
people kind of feeling like we've been
maybe more negative recently
i don't want
like a combative relationship which i
think
sometimes happens because we write about
things that matter and people have very
strong opinions about sure i don't know
like any any
anything race religion whatever
um
but i would like to get to like a point
where
people can
disagree but like in a civil
way i i want to have a relationship with
readers where
they trust
that even if we do not agree
that like we're not
saying or writing stuff just for the
clicks or just to make there's like a
lot of times when we write stuff and
it's like you were just trying to get
people mad or like you were just trying
to get a reaction out of people and
i guess i want to get to the point with
with
readers relationship with readers where
they trust our motivations a little bit
more uh because which is
hard because i think just generally
mainstream media there's a lot of like
skepticism and like
distrust right like sure after four
years of fake news or whatever
so tall order but
hopefully maybe we can we can get to
that point and i i think it's going to
require like a lot of thinking about
like
how to build community how to like
the word prune is coming to mind but
that's probably not the best
word
i want to have a good relationship but i
think it's going to take work to like
find and build the the community um
which
is hard when we don't have like a
community manager but you know when
we're talking about ambitions yeah in a
in a perfect world we have like more of
a
a give and take with readers it sounds
like uh you have your work cut out for
you
but you very clearly care a lot
and obviously that's important yes no
that's the person that is someone who's
worked with eic so i don't think have
cat that much so
you know it's
boy i wish that were me yeah i was gonna
say i just hope that you don't burn
yourself to the ground in the process of
caring a lot but i appreciate that you
do
we'll see i figure i give it a few i
feel like i've aged like three times
at a three times the pace over the last
three months so we'll see how long
this pace lasts but
you know you're not giving an
opportunity like this very often so i
figure
uh if i'm going to go all out if i'm
good
if i'm going to burn out it might as
well be for something that's like worth
it so
i don't love that but i also understand
where you're coming from i want to tell
you i don't want to burn out
i get it it makes sense
uh well thank you for joining me
patricia where can people find you and
do you have anything that the site is up
to right now that you want to promote
uh
yeah we have some good scoops on the
site uh you should check out kotaku.com
we just wrote about
qa testers at activision blizzard a very
dire stories
uh but also you know fun stuff like good
mobile ads so yeah visit kotaku.com i'm
on twitter i think my username is ex
patricia h
it is i mostly tweet about pokemon and
keyboards so
be warned
i will leave links in the description
below and uh thank you for joining me of
course and thank you for watching